REO winter continues to be the queen of  confidence as she rocks her sexiest -  swimsuit - yet it's awesome the Modern  Family star shared this snap over the  weekend wearing a flirty yellow one  piece with an interesting lacy cutout  the actress captioned to the pig ready  to relax in the spa hashtag get away  hashtag sister hashtag trip remember  curves are beautiful - the 18 year old  loves to show off on Instagram so when  Ichi caught up with her earlier this  year we had to ask about it you know  what I find interesting is people always  think I'm so you know 100% common I have  no insecurities but what I also like to  let people know is like I still have  insecurities although I've come a long  way it's going to take you know it's a  journey for everybody to find a way to  be able to love themselves completely  and never be insecure and I if there are  people like that then literally I batted  them